[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRITHPAL BHOGILL: So we're
going to do this thing in two
different parts.
So first, I'm
going to talk about
what API monetization
is all about,
how do you go about
monetizing your APIs.
We'll talk about some
framework pieces,
and then Mark will come
and share a success story
on how they went from
start to, you know,
in the journey of
monetizing their APIs.
OK, so this year
you folks may have
noticed that we are doing Q&A
a couple of different ways.
Of course, there's a
mic out here up front.
So towards the end,
we'll try and have
some room for time for Q&A.
But if you go to your Next app,
there's a Dory Q&A link on it.
You can also ask
questions out there.
As we go towards the
end of the presentation,
we'll be reading some
of the questions which
are posted out there.
OK.
With that, let's get started.
So when we talk about
APIs, as companies
try to transform digitally,
what they're really doing
is they are converting and
expressing their capabilities
in terms of products.
And those products
are nothing but APIs.
So clearly, APIs,
at some level, are
an underlying technical
detail, but they've
been elevated in
the digital world
to a business-level capability.
So in this picture
out here, you can
see various different
enterprise assets
that many enterprises
commonly have.
And they build
layers on top of it,
and then API enable
to be able to power
these powerful connected
digital experiences.
So what are some of
these experiences?
Well, for some it could be
building delightful apps
that are used by employees.
It could also be building
applications which
are serving your customer base.
Or in many cases,
these could be APIs
which are powering full-on
ecosystems with your partners.
So this session today
will touch a little bit
upon how to really unlock
new business models,
how to really grow
that ecosystem.
And we'll also hear
firsthand from AccuWeather.
So in our experience, just
like we have different maturity
levels for technology stacks
or certain technology aspects,
there is a certain
level of maturity cycle
with an API [INAUDIBLE].
In many cases, many
of our customers
start with a simple
project, which
is just maybe a single API
or maybe a couple of APIs.
Pretty soon, when that starts to
get a little bit more adoption,
it becomes a little
bit more mainstream,
and you start to
get into what we
call as a program, which are
much more than just one or two
APIs.
And ultimately, what you really
want to get to is a platform.
And what that means is,
in a very systemic way,
organically you are
organized as an API company.
When you think about being
API first at that level,
clearly you can
see, at this scale,
the impact grows from
talking about things
like developer
productivity, innovation, et
cetera to be able to
generating new revenue models.
So APIs essentially now
become these digital channels
where you're able
to grow an ecosystem
and get into monetizing certain
enterprise assets, which
you weren't able to do before.
And that becomes
extremely important
in the digital transformation
age, where companies
are expressing their
capabilities as products
which are nothing but APIs.
So let's take a
peek at, you know,
what's the motivation behind
trying to make sure that an API
program is successful.
Well, clearly, there is
someone investing money in it.
There is an investment
in the enterprise
that the corporation
is making, so it
has to be aligned
with business goals.
Secondly, you want to be able to
justify the return investment.
And last but not
the least is to have
the right level of visibility.
So one question which
commonly comes up
when customers start
embarking on an API program,
well, I have a slew of APIs.
Do I just monetize everything?
Turns out that's not
always a smart choice,
because there are certain
APIs we believe are the right
candidates for being
monetized, but some aren't.
So let's talk about what
are some of the APIs
that shouldn't be monetized.
Right?
So some examples out
here are ticket booking
or store location.
These are organic core business
APIs which provide value
to your consumers.
However, they provide and
derive indirect value.
So let's say, if you're
Ticketmaster, which also
happens to be an
Apigee customer,
they have an application
where you can go and buy
a ticket for various
kinds of concerts.
Right?
But that's not
something that they
would monetize because that's
part of the core business
that they're offering.
However, you start getting
into a section of APIs
which help developers--
and we're talking about
application developers--
which help developers build
revenue-generating apps.
So examples like weather data,
messaging services, and Mark
out here will talk about
how they have achieved that.
Think about you building
an ecosystem there.
Today, companies
like AccuWeather
are becoming more
of a data company.
That's their IP.
And there are many other
application developers
who would like to [INAUDIBLE]
that experience of taking
weather data and embedding
them in different application
experiences that they're
delivering to the customers.
That's a perfect example of why
that API should be monetized.
So do we just take
an ad hoc approach,
or do we actually
follow a process?
So turns out there's a
very well thought out
and trusted what we call as
API monetization framework.
And it's actually a very
simple five-step process.
So the first one
starts with identifying
what are your core valuable
assets that provide
some intrinsic business value.
Then, understand who the
audiences are, right?
Who's really going
to be consuming
those APIs, those services?
And then comes the main part--
how do you really bundle them?
So a package or a
product bundle starts
to get into think
data transformation,
think APIs are products.
So if you're the
product owner, how
do really bundle and
create a package which
is good for regular consumers
or direct consumers on one end,
and maybe have a
different earning
mechanism for your
partners if you're
trying to grow an ecosystem?
And then offer, which means,
once you have a bundle,
how do you offer
up those APIs to be
consumed with different kind of
rate packages and rate plans?
And then last but not
the least, measure.
This is a very important
part, because many times when
I ask customers, hey, how's
the API program doing, says,
the APIs are performing well.
Well, great, but that's
only part of the equation.
Are they deriving
intrinsic value?
How do you measure that?
Are the APIs being adopted?
Are they generating enough API
traffic from a set of partners
that you thought
should be doing that?
Right?
That becomes a very
important piece.
So what does Apigee provide
from a capability perspective?
So in this picture, I'll try
and just go from the right
to the left to make
it a little more easy.
So this is what Apigee's API
monetization platform is.
It's built on the core platform
with monetization capabilities
integrated into it.
So let's start from the
very right-hand side.
On the right-hand
side, what you see
are nothing but business assets.
These are the core enterprise
data assets that we spoke about
in the very, very first slide.
They are exposing modern APIs
at some point, or in some cases
you may need the
platform to convert them
into modern REST APIs.
Once you do that,
API monetization
has two facets to it.
One facet is you as
the API provider.
So that's one persona
that we tackle.
So as an API provider--
in this case, AccuWeather,
they are the provider of APIs--
you have a set of capabilities
that you need, such
as I need to bundle and create
a package around my APIs.
I need to be able to create
rate plans that I can associate
with that offering.
And more importantly,
I want to be
able to do metering, billing.
All those are capabilities
that an API provider needs.
Now you go to the other
side of the spectrum.
Those APIs are meant
to drive an ecosystem.
They're meant to drive
consumption across partners
and other constituents.
So for the API
consumer, you equally
need the ability for them
to be able to discover APIs,
for them to be able to
subscribe to certain rate plans,
and do things of that nature.
So all of that is transacted
through the developer portal.
And ultimately,
those APIs that we
spoke about are powering
these connected [INAUDIBLE]
experiences, and the
developer on this side
becomes the key entity
who are the missing
component in ensuring the
success of an API program.
So with Apigee's
API platform, which
is a full-featured,
full lifecycle API
platform with API
monetization built into it,
it is an extremely
comprehensive, flexible,
and extensible platform.
So we have a lot of
capabilities in terms
of the different kind of fees,
rate card options, freemium
plans.
You're able to leverage many
of the capabilities built in--
I'll show a very quick demo--
and use them to be able to
quickly monetize your APIs.
OK.
With that, I'm going to
do a very quick demo here.
I'm hoping the demo
gods are with us today.
How many people out here--
just a quick show of hands--
have used Apigee Edge?
OK.
Another question, real quick.
Promise that'll be
the last question.
Excuse me.
How many are monetizing
their APIs today?
Even if you're not doing that
through the Apigee platform.
OK.
Excellent.
So in this quick demo,
I'm going to cover
a few different aspects
of the core platform.
And then I'll also talk about
the monetization pieces,
as well.
So out here, I'm logged
into Apigee Edge.
This is our management UI.
And so I'm logged in.
Think about me as an API
provider at this point.
So I'm using this UI
to essentially build
what we call as API proxies.
So think about the
slide that I just
showed where you have a
lot of enterprise assets.
OK?
Those assets are nothing
but API that you have.
Either you own them
organically, or they
are sitting on top of
some packet application
that you have, or perhaps
some homegrown systems.
Think about Apigee sitting in
the front as a facade layer.
So when we represent
those APIs, we
do them by what we
call as API proxies.
An API proxy is nothing but
just a simple method definition,
a flow which says here's
an API call which comes in.
Execute some policies, and it
goes to a specific back end,
which is nothing but your API.
So API proxy happens to be the
number one primary construct
in the Apigee Edge platform.
Now, what happens is when
you, as the product owner,
in this case who owns
the portfolio of APIs,
you come into this screen
out here, which is what
we call as a product bundle.
So within the notion
of Apigee Edge,
you have this
concept of a product.
Think about a product
as being nothing
but a grouping of a
certain number of APIs.
So let's say you have 100 APIs.
And you may only decide
to monetize five of them.
Remember we spoke about which
APIs we monetize and which we
don't?
So if you think
about that bundle,
you could come in out here,
take that product bundle--
in this case, we just call it
Ad Service product bundle--
and this may have four or five
APIs that you want to monetize.
So in this product
bundle definition,
you define what your
transaction recording policy is.
So it's pretty simple.
Anytime you want to
monetize your APIs,
you want to be able to
ensure that you're only
monetizing those API calls where
you have a successful response.
You may have certain
errors with API proxies.
Out here, in this
definition, you're
saying which API
call do I really
want to be able to recognize
for monetization purposes.
So in effect, this kind of
becomes your system of record
for keeping track of which
APIs have been monetized.
So that's the kind of
stuff we declare out here.
Out here, we define which
specific resources within those
APIs you want to be
able to monetize.
And you can add specific
custom attributes.
All of this level of detail
is available to the metering
and billing engine.
As API traffic is being
piped to the API platform,
it is picking up
what you define out
here in terms of enforcing
some of those aspects.
Once you're done building a
product bundle, what you then
end up doing is
building a rate plan.
And this is really where
you have the ability
to create different
kinds of rate plans.
So we spoke about some of them.
So essentially,
you as a provider
will figure out what
kind of offering
you want to make for this set
of APIs or this API product.
You give it a rate plan
name, you pick the bundle,
and you pick the rate plan type.
So this is an example of
what I was talking about.
Now, you can monetize
APIs differently.
You can say, well,
you're going to pay
a flat fee for a monthly use.
I don't really
care about volume,
it's x number of
dollars a month.
You can pick fees only.
Or you can have a
rate card, which
will say here's a rate card
which says how many APIs,
and for what amount.
You can also do something
much more sophisticated,
where if you have a
partner ecosystem which
is getting traffic
onto your platform,
you can use a revenue share
arrangement where there's
a cut of a specific amount
of revenue, dollar amount,
that you as an
enterprise can ascertain
from that transaction.
So again, these are
various options out here.
I'm not going to spend
time on each one of them.
And then you can create
the start and the end date.
So as an API provider,
you've taken the APIs,
you've created a bundle,
and you associated that
to a specific rate plan.
Once that's done, the
monetization engine kicks in.
As API traffic
starts to flow, we
start recording based
on your preferences
those APIs which are meant
for recording purposes.
And then I'll very
quickly just hover over
some of the reporting capability
as a provider that's available.
So you can go create different
kinds of reports out here.
Revenue report, billing,
prepaid balance.
So again, from a
monetization perspective,
we have integration
into payment providers.
But many customers
of ours who already
have pre-built and
homegrown billing systems,
we can act as a system
of record and provide you
all the transactions
that you need to be
able to bill your customers.
So I'll show you an example of
a report out here real quick,
but Mark is going to cover
that in some more detail.
So out here is an example
of a detailed report
which can come in,
and it will give you
the transaction output.
So I'll see if I have
any data in here.
OK, so here's a
very quick example
of some transactions out
here and some recording being
done around certain
kind of transactions.
And again, this data
can be taken and dumped
into your billing system,
or, as I mentioned,
you can use other
capabilities from here
to be able to generate billing
and reporting, as well.
So with that, let's
go back to the slides.
At this point in time, I'm
going to turn it over to Mark.
And then he will walk us
through the AccuWeather story
and how they took
off the program,
and also talk about the
consumer side of the house
and how they tackle
certain things,
like product bundles
or rate plans.
With that, Mark, take it away.
MARK IANNELLI:
Thank you very much.
And first, we're going
to watch a short video.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOEL MYERS: I became fascinated
with the weather when
I was three years old when
I fell in love with snow.
And by the time I
was seven, I knew
I wanted to be a
weather forecaster.
So AccuWeather I
started in college
as a second-year
graduate student.
And AccuWeather is
now the largest source
of weather forecasts and
warnings in the world.
We've achieved this by
having the greatest accuracy.
CHRIS PATTI: So AccuWeather
was founded 56 years ago,
really on pen and paper,
serving business customers.
And over the last
10 to 15 years,
it's really morphed
into a digital solution.
And APIs have basically powered
that entire transformation.
JOEL MYERS: The API is a way
of feeding the best weather
information into other apps and
integrating easily however they
want to use it.
MARK IANNELLI: We've been using
Apigee for our API developer
portal for over 18 months.
And since day one,
when we literally
started with zero
developers, we've
now branched out to
over 50,000 developers
out there in the community.
A lot of people don't realize
how many products and services
are out there in the marketplace
using AccuWeather APIs to power
that back end.
We serve nearly 50 billion
API requests per day.
KATHY YAZZIE: Apigee
made it very simple
for us to set up self sign-up
for potential clients.
It gives us the ability
to monetize our API,
and also to offer free APIs to
people so they can try it out.
MARK IANNELLI: By having
access to analytics,
we're able to really get
real-time information for what
our developers are
doing, what they like,
what they don't like.
It allows us to make that
quick judgment to what we want
to do moving forward
in the future,
as well as helping
our developers
get better experiences
out of our APIs.
JOEL MYERS: The weather
forecast is more important
than it's ever been.
The weather can cause a
flight to be canceled,
rain out a baseball game.
It interacts with everything.
There are millions of
developers and potential users
around the world for this API.
They can take our
data and our forecast,
integrate it into
whatever they're doing,
and make it better.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK IANNELLI: All right.
Well, first I want to say thank
you very much for coming out
today, and thank you to
Apigee and Google teams
for allowing me the
opportunity to be here.
So as you saw, we're actually
coming up on our 57 years
at AccuWeather.
And really, the company was
founded on the principle
that Joel understood
the value of specialized
forecasts for people.
And what I mean by
this is he started
going to local
businesses in the area
and selling, like, to gas
companies specialized forecasts
to help them predict
their energy yields,
or to a local ski
resort and helping
them predict when they should
be making snow overnight
to be the most efficient
and save money.
Over time, doing this and kind
of selling these specialized
forecasts, he earned that
reputation for his value
in the service of
what he was doing,
and the company evolved
into newspaper, radio, TV,
and eventually websites.
But as you heard our
CTO Chris Patti say,
in the past 10 to
15 years, we've
really become a full
digital solution.
And that evolution
happened because of APIs.
But what makes weather
data so important?
Well, the fact is that the
weather impacts everything.
What you do, what you
wear, where you go.
Every day, you make conscious
and unconscious decisions
based on the weather, whether
you realize it or not.
That's why so many products
out there in the market
are using weather and
incorporating the weather
to enhance that
product experience.
Some products are
built specifically
around the weather.
Some popular examples is you've
seen phones, tablets, watches,
a lot of products out there
that give that information.
But there's a lot
of products that
have actionable and triggered
automated decision-making
responses, like connected home
products, smart thermostats,
smart cars, watches.
There's also been
smart health products.
One of my favorite ones that I
like to tell a brief story just
to understand use cases of
weather APIs in the real world
is a company called
Cohero Health.
Cohero Health has a brand
of connected inhalers.
And they use our
APIs in a way that,
for somebody with a
respiratory illness,
and they use their inhaler, it
calls our current conditions
API.
Over time, as you
begin to use it,
it begins to build a database
of that current conditions
information.
It applies machine learning
to it, tries to find patterns,
identifies potential
weather-related triggers that
are causing that
respiratory problem,
and it then uses it to
look at our forecast API
to try to predict when you may
have another asthma attack.
So I just always thought it was
a really cool, outside-the-box
use case of our APIs.
And it just shows
how powerful it
can be to enhance your products
further using weather data.
But Cohero is just one of
many enterprise clients
that AccuWeather works with.
We've been actually selling
APIs for over 10 years
at AccuWeather, not to
mention that AccuWeather
runs a lot of our own products
and services on our own APIs.
So Cohero and all
these other companies
up here help make up our 50
billion API requests per day
that we talked
about in the video.
I mean, I'm willing
to bet, actually,
that pretty much
everybody in this room
has at least one product
in their home that
is powered by AccuWeather
APIs on the back end.
That's how popular they are.
But the thing is, in
doing all the enterprise
partnerships that we
had, we began to realize,
we think we could do more.
We started to think, were
we missing an opportunity
with what we were
doing by focusing
on these large companies?
These are the biggest
names in the industry,
but the industry is consistently
growing and evolving.
So we wanted to make
sure we're looking
at what is the next
great idea, whose
potentially the next
big partnership that we
can work with.
So to get there, we created
developer.accuweather.com.
So in May of 2017, we partnered
with Apigee officially
to create this portal.
And the purpose of it is
it's a self-serve portal
to engage the developer
community in a new way.
We wanted it to be easy to
use and help us increase
our business and revenue
opportunities without having
to significantly increase
our resources to get there.
So how did we get
along this journey
to actually create this site?
I'm actually going to go back
to Prithpal's monetization
framework and go through this.
So the five key points--
identify, understand,
package, offer, measure.
To create the portal, we went
through this exercise kind
of on our own.
I mean, we had the recipe
for an enterprise success,
but it was a very custom
and time-consuming process
to kind of get to that point of
selling it to those customers.
So we started asking ourselves,
how can we translate this
to a self-serve environment?
How can we make this a cleaner,
more efficient process?
Again, not trying to hire
all-new resources to get
all the potential clients.
We wanted to have something
else simpler and easy to use.
Let them find us, come to us.
So the first step is identify.
For us, what sets us apart?
What would people
want AccuWeather,
or why do people
want AccuWeather
APIs for their own products?
As you heard Joel Myers, our
founder, say in the video,
I mean, our accuracy
is important to us.
We've been ranked number
one for the past three years
in a third-party study
for our accuracy.
We have a very truly
global service.
We have, like, over two
languages and dialects,
60 countries for
severe weather alerts.
I mean, literally
everywhere on the planet
we provide the weather for.
We also have a very
robust and efficient API.
And that's very important to us.
Again, 50 billion
API requests per day.
At times, we serve over
1.5 million API requests
per second.
For some companies, that's
more than they do in a day.
For some, more than a
week or even a month.
We're doing that at times
during the day in a second.
So we had the confidence
in our data as a product
and we felt it was
definitely unique to be
able to offer to our end
users because we feel
an API could be more
valuable for your audience
if it has impactful data.
And also, it has to
have an API service
they can trust and rely on.
So we felt we had these
with our enterprise APIs.
So next we had to think about
who's our new target audience.
So again, the weather
impacts everything,
and everything is
powered by APIs.
So we wanted people to use
AccuWeather APIs to power
their ideas and business.
But not just the big companies.
We wanted to work with the
startups, the small businesses,
the single developers,
the students, the weather
enthusiasts with
just a great idea.
But the problem was,
again, our sales
resources were very
focused on these enterprise
agreements in the space.
And the contracts
were very custom,
and it was very custom for
the content and the pricing,
and it could sometimes
take days or weeks.
So we knew we needed
something that was, again,
self-serve, quick,
something that
would increase the
opportunity without increasing
those resources.
So we started thinking, how can
we engage people on their own
and get them to come to
AccuWeather on their own,
without having our sale staff
consistently going after them?
So that led us to our packages.
And this is probably the
most interesting aspect.
I'll start with saying we
love Apigee's monetization
features because of the
options that we had.
We actually
utilize-- I know it's
a little blurry on this
screen, but we actually
utilize a base fee and
a monthly CPM rate.
We also offer a
free package, which
we didn't offer before,
which that alone is great,
because now people can
come to us, find us,
test us on their own.
But the base fee gives us
the ability to kind of set a,
so to speak, threshold
for API request limit.
And that base fee
covers up to that point.
But instead of capping and
cutting off a developer
as you're using the API,
we then have a CPM rate
if you go over that threshold.
And we loved that because
it gave the developers
more freedom and flexibility
to do what they wanted.
There was no hard cap
on our package limit.
We didn't want to stifle
developers' creativity.
The last thing you want to do
as a developer is worry about,
oh, great, my
product's taking off,
I hope my package
doesn't cut me off
before the end of the month.
So having that ability to
let them go over is great.
It lets them focus on
growing their idea,
not worrying about minor things.
But as we went in
through this, we
started to think about
what content do we expose?
For AccuWeather, we had
our enterprise APIs.
We intentionally did
not offer everything
from our enterprise
APIs on this portal
because the portal
does a lot more for us
than just simply automate a
new audience experience for us,
or a new target audience.
It helps us act as a sales
channel to lead developers
to our AccuWeather API,
and eventually, hopefully,
to our sales team for a greater
partnership opportunity.
So each package has
additional content
as you increase
in dollar amount.
But some content is still by
contacting our sales team only.
It's a more premium content,
more premium experience.
And we want to be able to talk
to those different partnership
opportunities to see
how can we help you.
Again, part of my
role, how can we
help you, how can
we work with you
to really leverage that API.
We weren't getting rid of
our enterprise sales process,
we just wanted to supplement
it, make it stronger.
Another thing we
had to think about
was our own lines of business.
Everything internally at
AccuWeather, for the most part,
runs on our own APIs.
We also have a lot of other
data delivery methods.
So we had to make
sure we were being
consistent and fair across
the board with our data
and pricing.
We can't be cutting out
our own lines of business
by offering a package with set
prices, but still not offer
other opportunities elsewhere.
So we had to be
cognizant of the fact
that we're looking
at all the ways
that AccuWeather brings data
to the people, and making sure
that was fair and
consistent across the board.
And then finally, the last
thing we had to be mindful of
is what our
competition was doing.
As any good business
would say, you
have to always be mindful
of your competition,
making sure that we're
still consistently providing
that accurate weather data
forecast and a reliable API
service.
We want people to come
to AccuWeather because
of the name and the
brand that they know,
but we want them to also stay.
You have to maintain
that consistency.
So now that we had
our packages, we
had to think about how
can we put it out there.
So by partnering with Apigee, it
helped solve another challenge
that we had at AccuWeather.
And that was making our
APIs easy to find and use.
People were unsure before how
to get to our APIs before.
The most common
way was that people
were seeing some
of the partnerships
that we had, and potentially
had a product in their home
or on their phone or
something, a widget,
and they saw the AccuWeather
brand label on there.
And they thought, OK,
there's data here somehow.
How do I get it?
And they tried to
call our sales team
and get started from there.
But then that's
another challenge.
There's a lot of
people that don't want
to talk to a sales team member.
Think about if you're a startup
company or a single developer
or, better yet, a student.
Do you really want to
talk to a sales rep
and go through a contract
and a legal process?
No.
You want to just go somewhere,
sign up and get started.
So by having this portal,
it made it much easier
for us to get the
word out there.
Let people find it, try it on
their own, sign up for free,
do some testing.
We wanted them to just
sign up, pay, and go.
No delay, no days waiting.
Minutes now.
Get started.
But once it was available, we
had to create a new marketing
campaign to try to get the
word out there and reintroduce
ourselves to the community.
Again, people weren't sure
how to find us before,
but now we're out there.
We have this portal.
So we want to let
people know about it.
The partnership with Apigee
has been great for us
because I mean, as you saw
with that commercial, that
was just a one of a
three-part series, actually.
We've also been on many blogs
and opportunities with them.
We've also leveraged
other Google resources,
like Google AdWords
and digital campaigns.
And as you see from all
this cool swag pictures,
we've taken it to hackathons to
kind of get the word out there.
And it's been really cool
taking it to hackathons
and letting the students
know, or other developers,
if they want to keep using
this after the hackathon,
just stay on the
site, sign up and go.
So it's bringing that awareness
and engagement in that way,
too.
But another thing
we had to do is
make sure we had a proper
presence on developer sites
and resources, like
even ProgrammableWeb.
Excuse me.
Our presence was confirmed
in studies like this one
from late 2017.
And I show this
graph specifically
because we launched
in about mid 2017.
So this was just after
the launch of our portal.
And this represents
the APIs and SDKs
that readers from their site
were most interested in.
And as you can see, users
had a very strong interest
in AccuWeather,
but if you actually
drill down into our profile
and read some of the comments,
people still didn't
know how to get to us.
We even saw people
saying, oh, you
have to go through a sales
channel, it's very difficult,
never mind.
Since then, now with the portal,
we've refreshed our presence,
so to speak.
We've gone to these
different resources and said,
we have this new portal.
We've actually seen
a lot of people
come through sites
like ProgrammableWeb,
found us, and then moved on
and actually purchased content.
So it's making sure you
have that proper presence
and reputation for your
product as you get out there.
So now that we felt we
had a solid new sales
channel at the portal
and a solid reputation,
it was important for us
to nurture our product.
And that you have to
consistently keep measuring.
So we do use Apigee Edge.
And these numbers
are actually, I
stole these or pulled these
out on Thursday of last week
as I was finalizing
this presentation.
So as you see, since May of
2017, that's our numbers.
And with Apigee Edge, we're
able to consistently monitor
growth like this.
We can get snapshots of
our users in real time.
It allows us to
quickly see any changes
we make to our documentation
or our marketing campaigns
that we potentially use to help
get the word and awareness out
there.
Are they being successful?
So it's been very helpful
for us to kind of get
that bird's eye view of those
numbers and growth and success.
But also with Edge
we can drill down
and get the individual analytics
for individual accounts.
So with this, we can see
what APIs are they using?
What APIs are they not using?
Are they doing something well?
Are there any problems?
Because that happens, too.
Are there any
abusers of our API?
But also, more importantly, for
product managers and the sales
team, are there any
new opportunities?
We can look at clients
like this and see
what APIs are they using.
Are they using excessively?
And we can see, is
there a potential here
to reach out to them
as a new client?
Because, again, we wanted this
portal to be a sales channel.
Not just something
to replace, but it's
something to actually help bring
us the most promising leads.
Let them come on
their own, hopefully
even with a small single idea,
continue to grow it with us,
and hopefully be the
next big partnership.
So it's really created for us
a great new lead generator, as
well, as well as just providing
an additional line of revenue
for us.
And then finally, you have to
monitor your overall health.
So with this, we can
look at our response
times, the volume, the errors.
We can consistently monitor
our overall health of the API
and make sure we're providing
that fast, reliable service
that we've been
come to known for.
Because if you can't provide
that good, reliable service,
why would anyone even put you
on their product to begin with?
The last thing you want to
worry about as a developer
is, oh no, my data provider
just failed for no reason.
No.
You want to focus on nurturing
your idea and your product.
You want to be able to grow.
But thankfully, developers
have been using us.
And since our
launch, we've already
seen some pretty
inspiring stories.
So we actually had a
young man come to us,
and he asked if he
could use our APIs
to power his tortoise habitat.
And what it is, as he said, his
family had a tortoise habitat.
And they used our
current conditions
API to actually help
control and automatically
trigger in the ecosystem
within that habitat based
on the outside conditions.
So it's automatically adapting
using our current conditions
API.
We also had another
gentleman come to us and say,
I have a backyard
awning, and I'm
using your API to
automatically power
it to open and close
based on the sky
conditions and precipitation.
And then he even reached
out to us and said,
your API is so easy to use
and we love the accuracy.
And they were both actually
just using the free trial.
So just, again, a weather
enthusiast or somebody
with a great idea, how easy
it was for them to go through.
And then finally, at hackathons.
This is actually a
picture from last fall
when we were at Penn
State University.
And what was great
to hear for us
is, as we take
this portal there,
students were coming
up to us and saying
with little to no experience
working with APIs,
they were able to
go on our portal
because the
documentation was clean,
easy to use using the portal
that we had with Apigee.
They were able to just go in
there and start developing.
They didn't have to worry
about how does this work
and how do I do
this, they were just
able to flex their
creativity and just
start building some
really great ideas.
So with all the success,
though, we still
see even greater
potential for ourselves.
We know there's even room
we can improve-- adding more
content, more pricing options.
So we're excited
about what we can
do with Apigee to enhance this
and monetize it even further.
So overall, we just
love the partnership
that we've been having with
Apigee and what it's done
for our developer community.
To paraphrase Joel
Myers, developers
are able to take our APIs and
make their products better.
Because for us, that has
always been the whole goal--
let developers easily put
the power of AccuWeather
behind their products
and build cool things.
[MUSIC PLAYING]